this already happened but I just danced
to Michael Jackson in the snowcone place
I'm gonna play that right now for you
would you guys think of my dancing whoa
it works just friend
okay
heroes I'm gonna buy some pirate gear
what should we get John already I just
don't know I think that's the vest and
there's a patch you can find link over
here Schwartz gangster parking only all
others will get Jack to become pirate
put your knife in your finish good I
can't really can't see that while on
this I will hook you but I patched am
line it's dead or dying he's dying
leaving CPR
I'll be on YouTube mr. Walmart's because
they don't have them in LA so this is
like a little special treat beautiful
I'm always positive you guys have seen
these commercials for 3d chalk better it
is I'll choose the shocking this is a
activity set we should get the activity
still let's do it look yes let's get it
oh I'm so excited so the world is our
canvas right Jen yes let's do this she
won't try to make that is it like the
commercial no commercial the little girl
goes like this
see if I can put it through here and if
everybody can see one doesn't really
work good well something wrong there on
the bottom